a senator Rick Scott joins us right now
a Republican senator from the beautiful
state of Florida senator thank you for
taking the time oh yes no don't you just
feel sorry for all these families that
are going through this one there they
might be losing their jobs right now or
don't know what's going to happen but
number two they're scared to death if
they're gonna get just four tests
positive so my heart goes out to
everybody and I well now seems like we
all know somebody that passed away and
that's gonna impact all of our families
so my heart goes out to everybody do you
also look at this the economic impact I
guess it was one of the reasons why
governor DeSantis held off as long as he
could on the stay-at-home measures but
now you have the measures in effect and
now you have policing the beaches to
make sure people don't gather in groups
of ten or more on that this this could
get worse a lot worse oh yeah I would
come I was on the phone with a lot of
businesses yesterday and they're you
know I some people are just scared to
death here's here's the positive you
know we we as a country now we are
taking drastic action we see what's
going on in New York now we see that
people are dying we see the growth in
the cases so my experience in talking to
people all over Florida our people are
taking this very seriously now they are
staying home as they can and they're
getting tested they can it's frustrating
right now we still don't have enough
testing sites up we can get results
quickly there's so the testing process
around my state and I think around the
country still has a lot a lot of work to
do because people want a quarantine if
they know they're positive but people
are waiting ten days as much as ten days
to get a result we gotta get this fixed
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
people scared what's going on right now
but I'm optimistic that we're gonna
we're going to figure this out I'm look
you know our health care system is a
great health care system they are going
to figure out how to treat patients when
they do that's gonna that's gonna
alleviate a lot of concern people have
you know on the senator your colleague
Marco Rubio had looked at the economic
impact of this to say nothing of folks
who are scared to your point
he said we got unemployed pissed-off
people they can't get benefits and when
they get them they're not going to be
enough
right now these are the folks who are
looking to this crisis right now charlie
crist was hurt by a bad economy
Republicans he says might be in the same
position right now do you worry about
that yeah well I mean look I'm worried
about people this is not about politics
you know this is about how do you help
every family you know most I went
through look I went through hurricanes I
went to mass shootings I went through
the ticket crisis I rented the company
there's there's always gonna be a crisis
and and what's gonna happen is people
are gonna come together and they always
do families do it
communities do the churches are involved
government can be helpful we're gonna
get through this and I think I think the
key is going to be if we all understand
that we cannot get infected we just see
every person says themself I am going to
not get infected then this will stop and
that's what's gonna happen and thank God
we have these health care workers and
the people are stocking our groceries
and things like that because you know
they're the ones that are making sure we
could all survive while we figure out
how to treat these how to treat these
patients
all right southerners Scott hopefully
you know this doesn't go on forever
so we'll see what happens here but
senator thank you for checking in with
us